this is the first time christopher wray
has testified before a senate committee
since the insurrection at the u.s
capitol eight weeks ago
i was appalled like you at the violence
and destruction
that we saw that day i was appalled that
you our country's elected leaders
were victimized right here in these very
halls
that attack that siege
was criminal behavior plain and simple
and its behavior that we
the fbi view as domestic terrorism
some republican senators have claimed
among those who stormed the capital
were anti-trump agitators fake
supporters bent on causing trouble
an idea dismissed under questioning by
director ray
based on your investigation so far do
you have any evidence that the capital
attack
was organized by quote fake trump
protesters
we have not seen evidence of that at
this stage certainly
christopher wray has been director of
the fbi since 2017. he was a donald
trump appointee
after he fired james comey he says in
his time in office
he's seen a tripling in the number of
cases involving white supremacy
that has been the most deadly area of
attacks domestically
in the past 10 years he also says
there's been a dramatic
increase in the number of arrests of
people who self-identify
as anarchists the big question for ray
was the january 6 attack an intelligence
failure by the fbi
he pointed to a report sent by a local
field office on january the 5th
it was as you noted raw
unverified uncorroborated information
that had been posted
online and my understanding
was that that information was quickly
as in within an hour disseminated and
communicated with our partners including
the u.s capitol police
including metro pd in not one not two
but three different ways
director ray says an internal
investigation is underway to see if the
fbi
could have done more should have been
more proactive
in protecting lawmakers from threats
that were being widely circulated before
the attack
alan fisher al jazeera on capitol hill